At Udacity we just released a new feature.
Text.
Tada! You'll be able to start seeing reading more so
it'll show up inside your courses.
But don't worry, we aren't going to make you read a novel or
a textbook but sometimes it's useful to leave text for you.
Like you might see GitHub instructions or
a project rubric inside a reading morsel.
But the Udacity classroom isn't too large.
We only have this much space to work with.
So, instead of forcing everything to move down,
we use an overflow to make sure that text can scroll.
You've probably seen something like this on other web sites.
Let's see what this looks like in CSS.
I will right click here, go to inspect elements,.
Inside Div Tools, we can see that the text on the screen has this CSS class for
overflow:auto within the reading-area class.
If we uncheck it, let's see what happens.
I'll click it and make Dev Tools disappear.
We can see that the text is flowing outside of the classroom and
into the elements below it.
And this is obviously a problem.
Let me go ahead and
turn Overflow Auto back on, and everything is safely back in here.
It's worth keeping overflow in mind in the event that you've got a lot of
text you want to contain in a small area